hello my name is mathias jesus away
and i will now show you how you can interpret the
results of your perpetrator
here your
date up takes a lot of work
visitors simply
click on the statistics calculator and
copy your own data in this
table
forget  don't click on table
teachers beforehand i
'll just use the example acts let's
say you want to find out
if gender has an influence on
salary for this you just want the
variable gender and income from
datatec you now automatically calculate
a test for independent samples
and give  you also get the zero
and the alternative hypothesis at the same time if
you want to calculate a directed perpetrator
you are simply on one-sided
perpetrator
now you can either read the results
from the tables below or
you simply get a summary
in words the male group has
low values for  the variable
income a  ls the female group
the levin test of variance equality found
that variance equality
can be assumed
a two-tailed perpetrator for independent
samples showed that this
difference was not statistically
significant with a value of 0.08
2 and that's how easily you arrive at the
interpretation for your  the culprit is
the automatic interpretation, of course there are
also many other tests
i would say just go to data
tempi and try it yourself it's
really very easy
and see you next time